hi i'm andrea o'hara from gene whiz
thank you for joining us for our talk
today
our talk is entitled gene editing
validation with single molecule
resolution using highly accurate hi-fi
reads and today i have mike lyon joining
us from pac bio
uh before we get started if we can just
have a little bit of an introduction on
aav
so aav or
adenosined virus is an option for a
delivery vehicle that can be used for
gene therapy
uh main considerations for aav include
the considerations for size so this is
limited to a range of approximately 5 kb
including our novel gene that we're
introducing
and the other thing to keep in mind main
consideration is that the overall
fidelity of the aav genome including the
itrs are critical for virus replication
and encapsulation
so mike before we dive more into aav can
you tell us a little bit more about some
of the innovations that you guys have
at path bio regarding lung sequencing
technology
sure thanks andrew and and so as she
mentioned um my name is michael wyand
i'm an fas manager i'm covering the
eastern half of of america for pac bio
and and i'm super excited to be here
today and talk a little bit about a lot
of the research that we've been doing
um you know over the course of our talk
here today i'll go over a lot of
different things i'll i'll set the
background to pack biosequencing in
general and then give some granularity
associated with some of the workflows um
and how easy it is to to kind of get
going and leveraging long reads for your
research and we'll dive into to a little
bit of the analysis and and and also
talk about all the different research
and collateral that we've we've seen you
know so as
aav gene-based therapies have entered
this clinical translation
translational phase and
commercialization we've seen
a pretty high adoption
a couple years with that so so again i'm
super excited to talk about how
we can help foster those experimental
strategies
and so just to to set the baseline to
the technology itself um you know
pac-file is a long-read sequencing
technology um we've been around for
quite some time and there are sort of
four staples to to the technology itself
we generate very long reads uh those
reads are on tens of kilobases of length
and they go out super long um and we're
able to sequence a whole host of
different types of applications and
sample type so we we sequence samples um
that are only a few hundred base pairs
in size all the way out to 50 or 60 kb
as the insert that we're actually
leveraging and trying to interrogate
in addition to sort of some of the
foundational pieces the pec bios were
able to achieve really really high
accuracy and so i'll show a couple
slides on that um
a little later when andrew and i are
diving into it as well um but again we
we see no systematic errors associated
to that and are able to achieve qv50
values um for a lot of our sequencing
types
and again for
specifically for aav one of the really
nice highlights to that is we are
allowed to get single molecule
resolution so we can really dive down
into you know the positive and negative
strands associated to these products and
be able to identify what's in there and
then on the back end you know there
there are some other things that that
suit to specific applications that that
can be really really helpful based on um
contact sequence context or or
epigenetic information that all comes
along with the sequencing itself
and so just to show a little bit more
granularity to the workflow again
this kind of layers on to a lot of
different of the application spaces and
not just specifically aav but um we you
know we can take anything from anything
that's double stranded and it works into
our into our pack bio workflow um we
create libraries and then we we put it
on our sequencing system so our sql
detection system uh this can be done in
in a a couple different arrays in sample
prep and library can be across the
different uh portfolio suite that we
sort of offer um and sequence a lot of
these samples all at once
so i did just in case the um the folks
that are attending and haven't done a
lot of sequencing i did want to speak to
to it a little bit right so previously
when you thought about it there were two
kinds of paradigms that you could think
about when long reads first hit the
market right or hit sort of a decision
making timeline you had to decide if you
wanted really long reads or really
accurate reads
and you know one would choose choose one
or the other and really kind of have to
plan their experimental profile out
associated to that well over the past
few years we've really made some some
startling increases and done really
really nice things associated to it so
now with pec bios hi-fi reads you can
get not only reefs that are super long
but that they're also extremely accurate
and so that allows you you know in one
data type to do a lot of different
things
yeah and i'm sure as you have noticed as
well as i have there's been a lot of
excitement about the hifi technology can
you explain this in just a little bit
more detail and some progress that
you've made in this space
sure
and so you know pec by high five reads
are you know leverage our single our
single molecule circular consensus
sequencing mode so you know people can
be familiar with tech bio but but again
just to baseline some of this
um we can take any sort of
double-stranded material and we ligate
on these these hairpin adapters the
polymerase reads our cells have become
so
long with the technology advancements
over the over the past few years that it
allows us to build a consensus
sequence
from multiple passes of the smart cell
leading to extremely accurate high fire
reads so leveraging this intramolecular
consensus it allows us to circular go
around that template many many times and
be able to do a lot of different things
with your research
and so switching gears and diving back
into aav how can this be used
with
as a qc for these gene therapy delivery
vehicles so many labs over the years
have been intensely focused on
developing aav strategies right um
a lot of aspects that these folks have
started to be interested in have
depended on long reads so
i've been around for a little while now
and sort of have been helping with um
djiv approaches for over five years and
and we've seen sort of the strategies
and efforts broken down to several
phased approaches
um whether it's discovery and just
general engineering or groups that are
aimed at vector design and trying to get
high quality vector qc um you know
others check the platforms and and
develop their editing efficiency and and
make sure that the changes that they're
making
are actually there right and making sure
that they're building out some of that
for for safety right and in terms of
these truncation events or different
things that they're going to try and
package and put into people eventually
so again one of the major advantages
that we've seen is that with back buying
these long reads you can reconstruct
these fragments um in silico right to
determine the template molecules and and
you know have everything as full length
and really understand what's in there
and what they've been able to package
so having having that type of resolution
has really helped um single vector
single vector problems
and so again we've we've seen this and
historically with aav approaches there's
been some trouble getting through
secondary structures right it's been a
big challenge for for second generation
sequencing technologies and and this can
be seen whether it's in coverage
dropouts or particular regions or
chimeric regions and so from a lot of
the publishing and a lot of the work
that we've done we've been able to see
that we don't have any trouble getting
through that and and not only get
through them but but again detect and
quantify
itr damage and repair inductors and
understand what's actually happening
exactly so can you just like talk a
little bit more about some of these
recent advances you've seen specifically
with aav and pac bio sequencing
so there's been a whole host of of
publications right and i have a few
screenshots here of some things that
there are some primary ones that that
i've worked
so again i wanted to layer that on in
terms of um you know some of the things
that i have a lot of familiarity with
but smart sequencing has been the only
method that can really resolve and cover
the entirety of the aav genome from this
the impact sequences of the itr to itr
without the need for for sequence
reconstruction
and so some of these publications talk
about reverse packaging of the genomes
you know originating
it from the plasma backbone or whether
they're looking for host genomic
sequence um but it's really allowed for
discovery and redefining the quality
control standards for this type of work
and so
i'll talk a little bit about a couple
different examples right so let's um
let's not just talk in in broad strokes
but but get down into some real world
real world information and so
this is a group um that over the past
four or five years i've worked very
closely with they're at the jorah gene
therapy center at umass university of
massachusetts and guanfeng gao's group
and they were able to show that you know
vector genomes that have been packaged
that were extremely
heterogeneous and so that was something
that was
really interesting to start right so
prior to that in a lot of their work
that they had been doing was was with
second generation sequencing
technologies and they thought that they
were packaging things
appropriately and so you can see
here in this screenshot this is an igb
snapshot a igb
igb display of individual reads aligned
across this is a self-complementary the
genome reference and this approach
really allows them to
understand the relative distribution
of truncated genomes and and sort of
understand full length versus vector
preps and so
since each one of these um
self-confidence self-complementary aavs
are actually a linear sequence they were
able to really kind of dive in and
illustrate the alignments associated to
that
and so another example is is from the
group um
at the sanger institute
so they've done a lot of different work
and a lot of different efforts over the
past um in trying to figure out
you know some of their gene editing
outcomes and really trying to understand
what what they have there and so with
with this group they they leverage long
reads to get across that um pig you know
pig allele locus so it was something
that you know they were able to span the
reeds and characterize the changes that
they were making
and and do this accurately so if you
look at the bottom left-hand side of
that figure from this nature biotech
publication you can see the example of
the alleles tracking right and tracking
those changes and tracking those
deletions that they had tried to put in
part
these are fantastic it's so great to see
examples of how scientists are
leveraging pac bio in the application
space
so uh can you tell us a little bit more
about what people we need to do to get
started or just a little more about the
actual workflow that you would need um
to use pac bio for these approaches
sure and so
this is something that's been great for
me to see you know having having done a
lot of this work over the past few years
so
early on we spent a lot of time with
with these workflows and trying to build
that out and
and it was it was a little bit of a head
head against the wall type scenario
right where we we really had to usher
things along and really had to hand hold
a lot of that and and so over the past
years we've we've validated these
workflows and started to build them out
so that way it's it's a much easier to
get along the experimental path so
you'll see in this in this sort of
screenshot here there's you know
procedures there's you know different
things associated to how you can
purchase it and and again walking
through the library construction portion
it's become a lot easier um you know in
terms of importing these things into
into workflows that we already have
established for for other amplicon
approaches and so i'll talk a little bit
about um
in the next slide a little bit about you
know how to convert those different
types of things and andrew and i will go
a little back and forth but it's it's
been a really nice thing to see how it's
evolved um and that these workflows are
much more streamlined
and so you know in general a lot of the
questions i get are built out around um
extraction right and so whether we're
you know doing particle or host cell
purifications and and how do we build
these different types of things out or
what what's within um the experiments
itself so for the pack bio workflows
we've we've generally used um either
single stranded aavs or
self-complementary aavs and and done um
taking those into our workflows um
you know there's been a lot of effort up
front and in a lot of publications and
research and i know that that a lot of
people have different flavors for for
this type of work and it's been
something that's been great working with
gene with so i know that they've
sequenced a lot over the years and and
so i've i've been happy to see how
that's evolved as well
yeah and i know just based on our own
customer experience at gene woods we're
really aware of this uh single-stranded
a double-stranded dna conversion step in
particular as it's a difficult step but
it's really critical uh for getting
everything prepared for the downstream
library preparation uh at gene woods we
have developed a proprietary method for
this conversion but once that's actually
done uh what happens next
so once everything's double-stranded and
again you know having that solution that
you guys have has has been huge because
it's it's generally been a hurdle or
it's generally something that i've dealt
with where
you know sites will either want to do it
themselves or they'll want to outsource
some of that information or some of that
research and it's been it's been
something that's really
really good to get over that hurdle once
it's once it's gone that far and it sort
of comes into the pack bio workflows
that's where it's pretty streamlined so
we we funnel it into our express um
template prep procedures our library
construction it's a it's a pretty short
turnaround it takes four or five hours
to make the libraries from input
material to smart bells and you know
having those hairpin adapters on either
end
and that's that's pretty standard
molecular biology um
where we've we've been able to leverage
all those different things that we've
done on a few different places um
you know after that the sequencing
preparation and some of those other
things that a service provider would
have are pretty straightforward again
we've we've had a few other workflows
and and so again trying to buffer for
how i would approach these types of of
um
strategy or doing long read sequencing
so this is a procedure there's a little
bit more granularity associated to it
and this would be one that we would
barcode right so you would put
barcodes in your hairpin adapters there
and allow you to pool multiple samples
together and this is something that
we've seen
a lot of customers leverage because it
makes it not only much more affordable
but then they can process a lot of
different experiments to get to a lot of
different discoveries pretty fast
and so once they have these libraries
all prepared what sort of a read length
can they expect when they're actually
doing the sequencing
so i've popula
sensor performance right of of outputs
and and so i talked a little earlier on
that we generated super long reads with
back bio and this is an actual histogram
of what those reads would look like um
and specifically for 5kb right so just
under 5kb for aav here um but you can
see that over half of the reads are over
100 000 bases in length and and even
though we don't need to necessarily span
all that information again talking about
hifi and talking about the approaches
that that hi-fi walks through right
where we're able to go around and around
it drives us to build out a very good
like intramolecular consensus sequence
so you see over here on the on the
right-hand side hand side of the slide i
have a mock of what an actual av library
would look like right so you'd have a
smart bell adapter on either side in the
blue
and then you'd have your sequence of
interest right your your single stranded
aav in this case or self-complementary
or whatever it would be in the yellow
and the purple and so leveraging that
read length that's on that base density
plot there you'd go around this molecule
many many times and that again allows
you to get
really good resolution associated to
what's what you're packaging so even if
things are aren't all full length right
and you have this large distribution of
of what you might have created you're
going to get really good sequence
accuracy associated to that
and so no matter what system you use in
in and you know the outputs can can be
um
be higher or lower and you have a lot of
different options for for how you want
to sequence and how many samples you
would pull together and all those
different types of things but but i have
pretty good guidance on that front which
is great
fantastic and so uh now we get to the
the best part right so we have all of
our results what does the analysis
actually look like for all of this
so i my background is in wet lab and
molecular biology so i'm definitely an
analysis hack here and i think that's
the the nice thing associated to it so i
have a little screenshot of kind of how
things work in pack bio landscape and
and this is something that i'm able to
do as well you know to speak to the ease
of use and speak to you know some of the
simplicity associated to it right again
you would you would walk through and a
lot of the stuff can happen in less than
a day
and you you know we have different
guidance whether it's on pac on our pack
bio web pages or whatnot
but you do multiplex samples that you
would pull together and run them through
a few different things and then that
would that would get you into your
secondary and uh
secondary analysis tertiary tools right
things that you're familiar with whether
it's igv or or anything on that's on
that front and a lot of that stuff is
easy and pretty straightforward and so
we have repos for all this type of
information and and again the message
that i want to kind of get across is
that a lot of that um
is pretty straightforward and pretty
pretty helpful and we've moved it along
nicely
fantastic uh yeah and so one question
that i get a lot um is actually if
you're able to tell any information
about what strand so again we were
talking about these single stranded
dnas uh is there any way that you can
detect uh strand specific information
using pac bio approaches uh in the
analysis or just in general
and so i i have a couple slides on that
to talk about it right so one to just
sort of walk through um you know some of
the sequencing output or how it might
actually be sequencing across and then
i'll show an example of of um of a
self-complementary aav so again
you know as you're sequencing across and
you're generating
this is you know what our normal smart
bell adapter would look like right so
you would start here with the blue and
you'd sequence around your templates in
your molecule because it's a 529
derivative or sequencing um
engine you go around and around at
strand displacing it allows you to
generate a super long read so so our
polymerase read that that 100 kb read
that i had showed just earlier it would
look like this where you would have your
plus strand you'd have your smart bill
adapter you'd have a minor strand and so
on and so forth and so the the analysis
that we we have in place for a lot of
different applications allows you to do
by strand analysis so you can parse out
those sub reads all of those yellow
reeds that have been tracked across that
100 kv read and you can line them all up
together and get an intramolecular
circular consensus read associated to
that
so if there are things you know that are
non-complement non-complementary you
know like
itrs you know that's or
or a self-confidence self-complementary
piece of of aav this would be one of
those things that you could do and you
could run across and so
looking at you know a little bit more
granular of what an actual output would
look like again you have your itrs in
here and this polymerase read would
track across that whole thing right
where you're you're going plus and minus
you're sequencing through all that
different type and that would be the
output that you would get that you could
then interrogate
and so you know again i wanted to speak
a little bit more and we'll talk a
little bit on the front of all the
different resources that are available
but
but you know as i mentioned this is a
repetitious live from earlier and i'm
i'm always a creature of habit for that
type of thing um and i wanted to show a
lot of the different pieces and
collateral that are there and available
right so
you know most of this is all written out
it's in procedures and it's been
something that we've seen a whole host
of adoption i showed a a screenshot of
some publications earlier
andrew made me parse that down i had a
giant list of things and it was pretty
ugly and and over consuming and it was
one of those things that there's been a
lot of research that's happened across
the landscape
absolutely
um and so
if you can just go to the next slide
mike
thanks
at gene wiz uh so obviously pac bio has
a great system in place um at gene woods
we offer a full end-to-end pack
biosequencing solutions for aav
this starts from
viral particle extraction includes the
single stranded to double-stranded dna
conversion
library preparation sequencing and that
downstream analysis as is true with all
of our geneless projects including aav
this includes a high quality data and
results with real-time updates
throughout the project from our first
in-class phd level support scientists
um
you know of course if you are thinking
of doing one of these projects and you
have any questions we always appreciate
uh talking to you all um
whether it's pac biodirectly or
for these aav projects so mike before we
wrap it up do you have any additional
resources you might recommend to our
audience
in in addition to myself yes um so one
one little pitch here would be go to the
back by a booth today as part of this
event it'll be great we'll all be there
i'll be there both days i have other um
colleagues that will be there to help
and and as i mentioned there's there's a
lot of different resources collateral
and i can answer direct questions
associated to that so so not only do we
have
webinar recordings or application
brochures high level things and and
things that really get down into the
weeds there's a lot of different
information and collateral associated to
it from the the front end all the way
through the back end so so not only
myself on the wet lab side but we have
bioinformatics fas that that are well
versed in this type of application and
are able to help um
continue projects along right so not
only sequencing it doesn't sort of end
there and it's one of those things that
we want to make sure that we shepherd
everything across and really get get a
lot of different resources out there so
in addition to you know as i mentioned
jean with um and andrea talked a lot
about their av and and sort of
conversion and so this is just a little
bit more granular screenshot to
something similar that we used to right
that you'll find
on our websites unpack bios webpage and
and again trying to layer in the ease of
use for the application and trying to
get you as much information as possible
and so with that i will
take some questions thank you
thank you
so mike i do have a few questions from
our audience uh the first question is
can you comment about some of the
differences between short and long read
technologies and what some of the pros
and cons might be for each
sure so we've we've seen a lot of people
leverage long reads right and you know
the primary differences that they've
been able to do against some of their
short read approaches have been
detecting the truncation infusions right
in in this single molecule
resolution allows you to investigate
these types of things and span that
whole gap again we're we're using super
long reads to cover lots of things and
and the fact that you can go around and
around the molecule and get that
consensus accuracy associated that can
give you pretty good confidence around
what's in the population in the mixture
right we've done early publications we
spiked it in on purpose right we we had
all these truncated genomes and he was
you know we were trying to to have a lot
of different types of things packaged to
understand the resolution that we could
detect and and i think that's been the
primary piece to it yeah
excellent and so when you're doing these
pack bio sequencing the next question we
have is uh what is the recommended input
material amount for pack biosequencing
and so this can vary uh pending you know
how big the experiment is or how small
it is um you know the procedure and
checklist that i showed earlier for bar
coding we'll
we'll we'll talk a little bit about that
in terms of how many samples you're
gonna pull together or how many that
you're gonna you know run a single
experiment if you're running a single
experiment the input will be a little
bit on the higher side it'll be a
microgram at least of material so that
can be a little bit heavy for a viral
prep um
you know but the as you start to pull
more things together or replicates or
something
those those inputs reduce right so if
you were doing four samples it would be
a couple hundred nanograms per right and
you match up to that that one microgram
lower level
excellent um and then one last question
i have here is uh regarding clia or glp
so uh if you're sequencing four clio or
glp is that the same or any differences
when you're doing path bio sequencing at
that level
well you'd you'd also know a little bit
more on that from me um no but the
libraries are transferable across all
that type of stuff so once you've made
that library you have the option to do
it you know research based or do a few
different things you know any and as i
mentioned earlier there were a couple
different systems that you have
offerings for right so high throughput
load throughput and all that type of
stuff so you shouldn't run into anything
once you've made libraries associated to
it but some of the other requirements
and again why i send a lot of folks to
gene whiz is because you guys know how
to do it really well yeah
great thank you
all right those are all our questions
for today it's been great having you
with us i'm so glad we had the chance to
chat
um and thank you everybody for listening
as well
yeah thanks everybody this was great it
was a it was an awesome opportunity to
have and we really appreciate it and so
my last little pitch for the booth too
right come ask questions i'm happy to
help if i can